45 seconds of goddamn forking logos this
may qualify is the laziest character
intro I've ever seen oh hey I'm driving
along a cliff ass Road and just saw an
oncoming truck but taylor swift's casual
sexy cool vibe tells me this is the
perfect time to turn my back to the road
and build something out of Lincoln Logs
in my backseat yeah she's on foam this
isn't a movie it's a distracted driving
PSA just like Hollywood
of course this girl wrecks dude and
natural phenomena and not her completely
death worthy unsafe driving I seriously
doubt a driver this reckless would be
wearing a seatbelt in the first place
yep
she's still alive and that's some bullsh
and after all that she's able to move
around pretty normally with no sign of
anything being broken her severe head
trauma she was thrown to the back of a
car and I'm pretty sure I saw a rock her
head on the steering wheel all things
considered this situation worked out
pretty well for her with all that
spinning around she still landed right
next to her cell phone so she could call
for help the filmmakers have found
another way to avoid clever character
introductions by just simply having
someone interview them so what's the
biggest difference between rescuing over
there and what you do here not getting
shot at lady he's cute go for it but the
information he conveyed actually
suggests intelligence not idiocy are you
even listening are you just making
doodles Natalie was also able to climb
up the car from the trunk without it
moving or coming loose I'm not feeling
very well coincidental end mass chips
we're coming to get you okay I even call
her at all helicopter rescues predate
cell phone technology by decades did she
really need a conversation to verify
that the fire department helicopter
hovering above her was there to save her
you're probably expecting me to send
this absolutely ridiculous helicopter
maneuver that seems to defy the laws of
physics and I will but even if it was
possible as soon as the helicopter got
close enough to the cliff to start
weed-whacking the foliage would surely
lose balance and careened into this
crevasse with the SUV containing the
indestructible teenage girl right just
how in the ever-living did this car
manage to fall to this point and then
think stop we got five minutes max but
why also what the engines going to fail
in five minutes how are they gonna get
back when they crash will believe the
LAFD will send a more responsible rescue
team to bail them out they alla need
three and look at super confident Joby
over here just three seconds ago he was
perplexed about not being able to use
the basket now I'm afraid he might
decide not to use the rope because he
thinks he's that awesome Oh oh no do not
go oh so now it's super critical that
Natalie doesn't move when she moved from
the trunk to the backseat the car didn't
budge but now that she's leaned forward
we almost lose the car the cameraman is
allowed to move freely around the copter
potentially interfering with this
delicate rescue mission
are they securing the car with the cable
that is attached to the helicopter if it
were to fall it would most likely pull
the helicopter down with it Jovie who is
supposedly a skilled member of search
and rescue and who previously warned
Nathalie of the dangers of making slight
movements in this delicate situation
decides to swing and tug at this cable
that is loosely attached to the back of
the car no wonder it slid down and
crushed his arm
strain happens to make the already
precarious chopper positioning even more
per car we really only eight minutes
into this thing oh no the gas prod meter
is almost up to 8 degrees Celsius times
100 I would be concerned if I had any
idea what that meant if I were Nathalie
I would not trust this statement since
the first guy tried to secure the
vehicle with a small cable and ended up
getting stuck I'm starting to think that
Joby is about to 127 hours is arm off
per car that was able to generally
withstand the beating it took to get
into the predicament we are currently in
it seemed pretty easy for him to just
rip that door off knew he doesn't have
cliffhangers balls and ends opening
scene without a tragic death
chomps he must always almost get crushed
by things every day for him to laugh and
shake his head like these are just
normal shenanigans also you've got three
people dangling from a helicopter over a
gorge one of them isn't strapped in and
one has a busted arm maybe wait until
landing to celebrate what you're too old
now too bad you can't because I heard
that the engine was going to fail around
now instead of dealing with the whole
getting back with a broken helicopter
that is flying in a crevasse that it
can't get out of situation they're just
gonna smash cut the caltech and talk
about earthquakes so many scholarships
were paid by the scenes Apple product
placement ah they dragged poor paul
giamatti into this didn't they
Anchorage Alaska 1964 a 9.1 that's very
close professor but it was a 9.2 it's
okay it's not like something like that
could be easily Google and spawned a
tsunami eighty-two feet high that
leveled Hilo Hawaii I don't mean to
nitpick actually I do it's the whole
point but that tsunami was only 35 feet
high the Internet is a beautiful place
I'd say it's not a matter of if it's a
matter of when said the earthquake
professor just days or even hours before
a huge earthquake proves him right
volleyball team has our first game this
weekend so there isn't a scene where
Blake plays volleyball in the movie I
can't believe she's in college already
you can't believe it she looks like
she's almost 30 maybe she's been held
back for ten years and he means he can't
believe she finally made it to college
let's go check it out and now for a
message from our sponsor Alexandra
Daddario may have been genetically
engineered by scientists to be in movies
just like this one I'm sure I could
figure out a way to put it in no one on
set said that's what she said causing
the director to change Ray's line just
in case you weren't able to glean that
rayon is why
aka Blake's mother are no longer
together here are some divorce papers
also our divorce papers usually served
with big red all caps letters seems like
this law office is run by a vengeful
high school English teacher snooping in
your daughter's dream box those days is
vikon again the huge they were able to
prove their magnetic pulse rate theory
literally seconds before a huge
earthquake that will then trigger the
worst earthquake outbreak in the history
of mankind talk about that timing or bad
writing a 7.19 a tude quake is nothing
to sneeze at but I don't think it would
destroy the Hoover Dam which is
essentially a 6.6 million ton wedge of
solid concrete unless there are
Decepticons living under it and I've
been able to completely rule that out
where are this girl's parents this guy
falls like this but somehow had in a
force and momentum to utterly impale his
goddamn foot on a piece of rebar
good catch seemingly out of shape
professor it also worked out that you
were right at the edge of the crumpled
free zone shouldn't have worn a red
shirt to work this woman is a dick and
she didn't even say thank you it'll give
me an opportunity to catch a volleyball
game a grown man going to a girls
volleyball game by himself never looks
okay
objects in mirror may be more divorced
than they appear sophisticated rescue
operation under way based on the first
operation we saw from these guys I think
fairly sophisticated maybe over selling
it that I respect what you and your dad
have but I'm never gonna try to change
what you have with him the classic I'm
not gonna replace your dad now that I'm
living with your mom cliche it stepdad
101 really Alexandra Daddario isn't my
stepdaughter in this scene wait that got
weird but also better am i right dan
unimpressed movie about to set a lot of
its action in San Francisco gives me 20
damn minutes of sweeping establishing
shots and does it won't show the Golden
Gate Bridge
of course the sin I'm removing for that
will almost certainly be added back
tenfold later when the movie caves and
shows us the earthquake destroying the
Golden Gate Bridge but whatever sin
remove for restraint for now Trump look
how extra sad you should be about his
death via this expositional photograph
people need to know that we can protect
these things now don't we cannot why are
they I can surprise if there's an
interview going on they're the ones that
let the reporter in the office the
biggest jumps coming from San Francisco
this guy is bouncing between Russian and
Scottish more than 20 points higher than
what we saw in Nevada
how is there no way the San Andreas
Fault is a very large and well-known
fault line the one in Nevada wasn't big
enough for them to already know about it
and Lawrence is the same guy in the
classroom that was all were 100 years
overdue and it's not a matter of if but
when I don't think Lawrence knows where
San Francisco is he just dropped a
sharpie 40 miles south of San Jose
call everybody I think I might have
finally figured out what's wrong with
modern screen right it's written for
moments instead of story or logic lines
that make sense
coffee spill meet cue cliche you know
you're quite beautiful do you mind if I
get your phone number for it
Olli Olli when did this turn into a Nick
Hornby film where you from England
uh no care to be a little more specific
the CGI work on this rooftop pool party
is straight out of The Sims we generally
don't like to make fun of people for
their appearance but god damn dude
change your controller already or should
I send the director for doing too many
takes in the hot Sun your other one
drowned in an accident it's good that
Daniels sisters an asshole so we didn't
have to get in too deep with the gaines
family history to find out what happened
to that other girl in those photoshopped
pictures that ray was looking at him
played through into the row funny this
is just the first of many times ray will
completely ignore his civic duty to save
his family members and friends isn't he
supposed to be headed to Nevada would it
be frowned upon if a trained rescue
pilot would abandon his family and
essentially steal an L a rescue
helicopter to go rogue and rescue his
ex-wife thankfully laptops electricity
and Wi-Fi all keep working during this
record huge earthquake movie rips off
the outrunning an earthquake thing from
2012 which if you're going to rip off a
movie is definitely the one you aim for
also it's pretty amazing that no other
cars we're trying to get out of this
very busy building except them when the
earthquake started and even though the
floor the parking garage gets knocked
out it creates this convenient ramp so
their limo doesn't get completely
destroyed as it switches floors
come up gone as if this meet-cute
romance wasn't already trying enough
would be stepdad who granite is
recovering from nearly dying pieces out
completely and leaves his girlfriend's
kid to die which would happen if only
discount younger Hugh Grant here weren't
conveniently around to witness it all
and figure it all out
Mike you should really be trying to
utter his young brother out of the
collapsing building this is the exact
same attitude that gets little girls
abandoned on top of the amps it seems
like it's taking the Hollywood sign
longer to come down and the Hoover Dam
tip will be quite casually kills tens of
thousands of people but thankfully not
The Rock's ex-wife how many people does
she think the rescue chopper is going to
hold
also that building is coming down fast I
wouldn't listen to the crazy lady that
thinks we should all go to the roof
either she should be dead two or five
times now if not for the ex machina
ferry
no burns sure okay look at the heels
Claire Dearing can't hold a candle to
Emma Gaines it's weird how Emma climbs
on another rock formation that looks
identical to the one she climbed over 15
seconds earlier is this the helicopter
equivalent of the urban legend about a
guy who switches on the cruise control
in his van and then climbs back to take
a nap yeah this buildings definitely
collapsing entirely just as soon as she
gets onto the chopper in a moment where
Emma fears for her life she decided to
stop running toward the helicopter of
safety and watch a building collapse the
helicopter and Rey's vision seemed to
still be operating normally even though
they are both engulfed in a cloud of
debris ray seems surprised that emma is
there even though the basket was over
100 pounds heavier than normal do you
think City Bank and Bank of America
funded the movie with the stipulation
that their buildings not collapse
seriously half the LA population dies in
this movie and we're going to be happy
at the end just because some hot girl
from bourtzi Jackson is still alive I
almost forgot about this bullsh during
all that other Bulls all this time and
she still hasn't thought to reach
forward with their left hand try sliding
or tilting the driver's seat forward
with the controls that are commonly
found within arm's reach of her current
position her cell serves just what
happened it's a small miracle that she
was able to get cell service in a
parking garage below a half crumbled
building in the first place we're going
to get our daughter Los Angeles the city
whose citizens that are currently dying
pay my salary then we've learned from
the past and Furious franchise and we
know family comes first
oh there's a beam on her legs now
wonderful glad I had no idea about that
until now to the point that was sinning
the seat recliner dickheads visual cues
yo give them I hope he put excellent
problem solving skills and quick thinker
in stressful situations on his job
application to get away from these
buildings too bad you're in the business
district of San Francisco the only way
you could get away from the buildings is
by jumping in the bay you need to see
this you better come take a look at this
cliche Oh get your laptop let's go
because the Wi-Fi is definitely still
working all over the everywhere
oh yeah man am I supposed to believe
that broseph McGee over here was going
to hack into a local media outlet after
a major earthquake I guess so I know
times are tough but this is still
looting yeah I got out I'm okay if all
the cell towers between San Francisco
and LA got knocked out what are the
chances that a landline phone would
still work the earth just opened up a
50-foot gap between two cities pretty
sure none of the phone lines would work
either
movie thinks we still need evidence this
guy's a dick hit you know that Blake
keeps pictures from our San Francisco
trip yeah in your memory box the parents
that snoop together ultimately stay
together
I feel like an experienced helicopter
pilot would have been able to anticipate
this he was just flying through a large
amount of debris and got hit by a giant
piece of building even I a two-time
RadioShack remote-control helicopter
pilot knew to keep an eye out for that
on that dollar rotate down auto what
gonna crash
even though autorotation is an actual
thing it isn't nearly this traumatic
what he's doing doesn't really look like
auto rotating either
it looks more like normal crashing good
thing they didn't crash-land into a sex
shop otherwise changing out other fuel
covered clothes would take an
unexpectedly sexy turn it's joy uh well
yeah two wrongs make a right I've been
needing that truck if I saw the rock
trying to take my truck I'd let him have
it even if I had a gut because he could
probably do that cell towers are down
most of the city's electricity down but
phone lines are miraculously still
working and this ragtag group of Caltech
media hackers are able to take over a
local news channel even though it's
happening here in California you will
feel it on the East Coast is that even
seismological e possible I'm being
serious while still sending it until I'm
told otherwise also earlier they were
only able to predict the 7.1 earthquake
that took down the Hoover Dam seconds
before it occurred but now Lawrence is
using that same prediction model to
predict a nine point five magnitude
earthquake hours before it occurred did
he get that much better at predicting
earthquakes in the amount of time
between the two quakes ray a search and
rescue experts seem to think it's okay
to walk to the edge of a presumably
volatile crevasse well they're
definitely not going to jump from one
side to the other or anything thank God
he didn't wear his John Deere hat that
day okay just thinking about all those
dying Los Angeles citizens I abandoned
with City property to come save your ass
I really made a moral with step I'm so
sorry for how things ended without set
why you're clearly gonna be back
together by the end liar liar' style so
if you couldn't save our daughter
all respect to helicopter rescue pilots
but maybe a lifeguard thankfully this la
fire and rescue chopper pilot also knows
how to fly planes I'm guessing if they
encounter any hot-air balloons or b-2
bombers he'll be equally as adept do you
mind if I ask why you wear two of the
same
you mind if I ask why you're paying so
much attention to Oh Who am I kidding I
know why you're looking there we are now
leading plausible things she would know
because her dad does search and rescue
and Entering why on earth would she have
known that territory also why is that
cop in the background letting her loot
from the fire truck sure that would be
milk in the highest point in the city
it's not even close to true there are
several other hills in San Francisco
that are higher in the immortal words of
the gas station attendant from Tommy Boy
get yourself a new map also there is no
way a British child wouldn't collapse
into a fit of giggles after saying Nob
Hill it's the cultural equivalent of an
American kid saying dick Mountain it's
been a while since I got you to second
base well I hope we've given everyone
enough morning he seriously just said
that right before this for real
uncapable earthquake premises die humans
die ahaha this movie should have been
called it's so goddamn lucky any of our
main characters survived this biblical
movie thinks if it destroys the Bay
Bridge and not the Golden Gate then I'll
go easy on it but movie is wrong this is
the same thing and movie knows it okay
unknowable things how do we get through
that
Apes lots and lots of apes wait she
pulls this piece of glass out as slow as
impossible she's evil get some weight on
it miraculously he can put weight on it
whatever steroid protein smoothie the
characters in this movie are drinking I
want some I said I would hope so I
always he not going full-speed already
the tsunami is about to crest and
they're just moving toward it with not
full speed until now this scene involves
several boats racing to climb over a
tsunami wave before it crests
they basically bone dry come on oh hello
Daniel I forgot that you existed because
you stopped adding anything to the story
after you left Blake it's too bad that
Emma won't know that you just got
smashed by a shipping container or maybe
it would make her even angrier because
she didn't get to kill you yep there's
that sweet sweet Golden Gate destruction
we as movie-going public so desperately
crave why are all these people standing
around right here when the tsunami was
visible at this point anyone who's still
on the beach deserves to die
considering this and the heart necklace
floating through the water earlier it's
James Cameron licensing cliches from his
other films for some extra cash if you
actually sit down and watch this movie
you may notice more times like this one
where they surely should have died but
didn't I'm just getting tired of
pointing them out so here are 10 cents
are you kidding me there's no way that
Ray could navigate through all that crap
without having something get in the
boats engine
I can't even dream up a fake reason to
make it plausible how many humans are
they running over right now though Jesus
Christ look at that damage you know
whose point of view I'd like to see in a
disaster movie an insurance claims
adjuster she's a smart girl she's not a
head for one of these high-rises Palvin
the high-rises that are almost all
collapsed except for like three of them
tell me again why a smart girl would go
to the top of a high-rise during a
massive earthquake I'm listening
I want to hear that reasoning pay no
attention to my wet shirt or my super
cleavage we've got to tend to your leg
if he thinks this kiss is in any way
earned in this way unfinished floor of a
skyscraper under construction should be
no problem BRB roland emmerich watch
this movie and in this order got a boner
jerked off and filed a copyright lawsuit
this asshole is ignoring the rescue
leading citizens of multiple cities in
pursuit of rescuing his own daughter and
he should be fired court-martialed fired
a second time and publicly flogged no
one thinks to break a window Blake seems
to be selectively resourceful the laser
pointer still works after being
underwater every laser pointer I've ever
owned just stopped working after a day
for no reason I'm bringing her back I
promise
uncapable on with the fuck do I care my
favorite thing about this movie is how
little it relies on cheap sex appeal
mm-hmm
what was I saying is ray really gonna be
defeated by a folding table and some
office chairs jamming a doorway earlier
the man pulled an actual door off an
actual car I'm getting real tired of
everyone ignoring the giant gash in
benzylic ray was for some reason unable
to do this three minutes ago instead of
backing out the boat through the hole
images made they decide to drive all the
way through the now collapsing building
and tear through the other side of the
building like parchment paper
skip ah I didn't try hard enough before
cliche aqui CPR tip the length of time
someone's brain has been deprived of
oxygen is completely irrelevant as long
as you perform chest compressions with
stubborn conviction say things like I'm
not gonna lose you too so he gets the
redemption of saving a daughter from
drowning and all that had to happen was
millions of people died two major cities
are destroyed and the map of the world
has literally changed but his daughter
didn't drown
so that's nice thanks to local experts
who were able to give ample warning of
the massive quake the news in their
version of America is painfully
optimistic they aren't looking at this
in terms of LA and San Francisco being
mostly full of dead people this movie
hits most of the key cliches lead
character we need to get back together
with his ex his child is in peril
meet-cute fall in love during crisis so
on and so forth but the one thing we're
missing here is a rescue bet oh look the
rock the Golden Gate Bridge a brilliant
sunset this couldn't be more the
American version of a Harry Potter
ending of a try I found this on the boat
that Nicholas stater on her neck through
the entire film but falls off of her
while she's sitting on the book did he
find it floating in a giant container of
water in the boat I hope so because if
not there's nothing to explain why I was
floating around in water by itself
during the title sequence of the movie
oh my god my god
you
who should we call everybody break this
information down succinctly the Klingon
Empire has roughly 50 years of life
lived - you did good huh Superman does
good good doing well which is why when I
get out I'm gonna put a hurt on him so
bad he's gonna wish his mother kept her
legs closed